There are, however, some issues with design methods. You as a architect or
designer have to make some choice. Are you going to go do things top down,
bottom up, inside out? There are a variety of choices there.
Are you going to begin by thinking of the procedures and functions? Or
are you going to begin by thinking in terms of the nouns and objects like you
would with objectory development. A topic which we'll come back to later in
the lesson is the issue of conceptual integrity versus cooperative development.
An important decision in many, software development shops is the trade off or
the tension between doing a design that takes a little bit more time.
In order to save yourself effort and money in the long term,
by supporting maintainable and general structures. Or are you going to be
dominated by short term delivery schedule. And finally, is the role of tools.
What, what tools are you going to use in terms of your particular design.